[MUSIC PLAYING]
It was pretty hard
to get people to join
Infinite a lot of people were
like, oh it's like too hard.
Like I don't know
how to do that.
And I think, for me, I
study human centered design,
so I started being
really methodical
and using a lot of
those design practices
that I learned in class.
So doing researchers, doing
some research like well
could be like the pain
points, as we say in design.
Is it a problem
of representation?
People don't see people
like them doing that work.
Is it other problems, like
do we need more mentorship
within Infinite to help people
get these projects through.
Like what drew me to
collaborate in theater
is that you have no choice.
So I'm interested
in why you chose
to collaborate in the visual
arts, which a lot of people
think is a very
individualistic medium.
Allan and I, we're twins, and
ever since we were little,
we both always collaborated
on various art projects
and it was always
something where
we felt as though if we worked
together on an art project,
we would be able to accomplish
a lot more and in less time.
And also the ideas
that we would create,
if we collaborate and jump
ideas between each other,
it would just be better, or more
innovative, or something more
creative than if only
one of us worked on it.
So then when we came
to MIT, we really
looked for an art
community to kind
of replicate that experience.
But when I started actually
working on my project,
I realized that it's not mine.
When I tell somebody
about my project,
then it becomes our project.
Like I auditioned for Emerson.
I auditioned for
vocal jazz ensemble.
And I would say like a
lot of my best friends
are people that I met
doing music stuff.
But if you find that one
goal, that one passion that
unites people around it and you
allow freedom of collaboration
and freedom of speech,
basically, freedom of merging
and moldings different
things together,
I think that is super beautiful.